no borders no nations these are slogans
that some would rather the Pope didn't
see so they are painting over the
critical graffiti at the Moriya refugee
camp the biggest of its kind on the
Greek island of lesbos this fortress
behind me will be the first stop for
Pope Francis on his visit there he will
meet some of the 3,500 few G's that are
waiting behind these walls for their
asylum claims to be processed they are
sealed off from the outside world and
guarded around the clock it is a
completely different world just a few
kilometres away the holiday paradise of
lesbos but since last year the island
has become a symbol for the plight of
the migrants around 700,000 have come
here by boat in the last 12 months and
it's their fate that concerns father
Leon he's the only Catholic priest on
the island and on Saturday he will be
the pontiff's translator Oh papa
delicate is organic Texas the Pope isn't
coming here to perform or to make a
gesture or to be filmed by the cameras
she wants to meet refugees and shake
their hands do you want to see the
reality and I at least will not be
hiding anything from him shortly then
that will Apocrypha but father Leon will
only be able to tell the Pope about
conditions on other parts of the island
the schedule is tight Pope Francis won't
be visiting this place for example 1,300
migrants in an open camp on the east of
the island their status is particularly
precarious but still they're pinning
their hopes on the Pope it's hope that
if he came and sowed the situation he
might help a lot but I I've got no idea
what what's the things that he might
help in people ropa listen new Papa
every everybody here took about the
becoming his he will help even by his
words it's very nice think anyone help
even in one word is enough for us the
citizens of lesbos are also hoping the
visit would give them a boost
today deputy mayor geauga katsaros is
hosting the European flag ever since the
start of the migrant crisis people here
have felt abandoned especially by the
you yagi mia fora dynasty the whole
world will be looking at our island and
I think that will do a lot of goodness
they will finally need to give a support
here unless loss hola show cosmos
propina Bowie fishy don't you see this
Leslie but it is unlikely that the
Pope's visit will have any effect on
Europe's migrant policy the next major
wave of deportations could come as early
as Monday and many of these migrants
will then be taken from the camp in
Moria back to Turkey